nous avons rendez vous avec un
commandant ukrainien souriant aubry met
en colère yuri bereza dirige l'un des
bataillons d'infanterie du front est
il donne ses instructions pour mimer un
pont et il s'énerve contre ces nombreux
civils qui ne se décide pas à évacuer
les villes du dombass
civile c'est un vrai problème impossible
de regarder devant nous on regarde
derrière où sont les civils comment les
épargner et on se dit ça pourrait être
ma mère celle de ce soldat énorme
problème et dans toute l'ukraine ces
problèmes en grèce
barghouti est l'illustration de cette
difficulté une ville clé toujours aux
mains des ukrainiens mais sous le feu
intense de l'artillerie russe nous y
arrivons sous des détonations ans et
ce bus jaunes évacuent des civils à bord
cette femme et sa fille elle accepte
enfants de partir après avoir longtemps
hésité
oui oui finalement par
c'est trop dangereux
étonnamment 30 à 50 % de la population
de la ville est encore là les accalmies
même courte sont une raison de rester
chaque jour 300 à 400 personnes viennent
dans ce centre humanitaire
distribution de vivres de vêtements et
de médicaments
à post oui c'est dangereux mais ici
c'est chez moi et je pense que tout ça
va s'arranger
face à ce déni dans cet hôpital des
soldats grièvement blessés sur ce front
est il raconte la bataille d'euros
busines villes prises par les forces de
moscou et leur unité empêcher d'utiliser
des armes lourdes contre les russes
on n'a pas pu utiliser notre artillerie
contre les russes parce que nos civils
étaient au milieu
on allait tuer notre propre population
lahesalu manoeuvrer trouver d'autres
solutions
les volontaires qui conduisent ces bus
encourage donc les gens à partir sur
leur route des militaires qui les
remercie pour ce travail de fourmi
on doit pouvoir faire notre travail de
combattants au lieu de ça on gère les
civils pour qu'ils ne meurent pas et
c'est comme ça que l'on perd des
batailles
malgré ces bombardements malgré ces
immeubles d'habitation détruit beaucoup
d'habitants de cette ville stratégique
de barghout refusent de quitter les
lieux il n'écoute pas les conseils
donnés par les autorités